from MIT and I'm a program director of a
project called visualizing cultures and
while we make the transition I was
struck this morning as I was getting on
the shuttle it was about a decade ago I
was in Las Vegas at a conference called
digital Hollywood and I was I just
produced a project an educational
television series and online project
called out cam kids and and it was it
was the the purpose of that that the
development of this project the people
that had funded the building of this
piece of educational media content was
that you know to not have the only thing
available on this if this new resource
the internet that was exploding with
content video and still imagery and text
was was videos of people swinging cats
around by their tail and that is as
Peter Kaufman said this morning one of
the things that I am heartened nearly a
decade later to see that you know here
at Columbia there with with all of you
people we are here and charged with just
that creating creating educational media
content that has value and relevance and
this is this incredible medium of the
web a little bit about visualizing
cultures and what it is visualizing
cultures is part of mi t--'s
OpenCourseWare initiative and that's
that's more or less our distribution
channel we are a course at MIT but
largely what we we like to consider
ourselves is this is a functional
platform for for media and content that
examines the historical record through
the images that were created at the time
visualizing cultures does a number of
things and functions on a number of
levels technologically in terms of
content delivery
pedagogically and and in terms of its
models the project was the was the the
genesis of the project came several
years ago with Professor John dower
who's a fairly noted well-known
historian at MIT winner of the Pulitzer
Prize you know who had wanted to wanted
to use what he had always done to
research his content and develop his
develop his works was was iam images he
based everything he did on imagery
everything he wrote was based on on
scanning that was the visual historical
record and what the the problem in in
his in both the Academy and and and and
publishing up to that point had been
there is no way it is cost prohibitive
to cost prohibitive to produce and
publish works with color images in them
so John was relegated to writing 600
were texts with with with a dozen or so
black-and-white images stuck somewhere
in the middle of that tome and suddenly
this is a man who today still does not
use email this is true I get all John's
email which is a horrible thing to this
day does not use email but saw the value
of using using the Internet as finally
the distribution channel that would
allow him to wrap text around imagery in
a way that would add entirely new value
and relevance to that image to those
images and to his text and and that
doesn't sound like a lot but that was
really a big deal in terms of John's
thinking and his capacity to be able to
do that and I think with people to be
able to absorb scholarly content and
historical and cultural materials so
what we call what what we do at
visualizing culture is something we've
we've we call digital image scholarship
and essentially we look at we look
visualizing cultures is a platform a
bridge between what content the amazing
rich depth of content that museums and
other cultural institutions hold in
their repositories and scholars and and
other experts and the knowledge that
they bring to contextualize that content
and those different media and so in that
way we hope to be we hope it is our goal
in our mission to to by bridging those
two things we had we had context to that
material and we we had we have we allow
access to the materials as well for
everyone for everyone to be able to see
and and interact with the great the
great and rich cultural materials that
were that have been created throughout
history media is not new so let me take
you through a little bit of what the
content what the content looks like and
what the platform is we have units and
because John is a historian who
specializes in Japanese history most of
the content that we have thus far is
focused on on Japan and and effectively
modern Japan Edo period to the to the
present eighteen 1850s to now and what
what we are doing is expanding that
content to include other other cultures
other countries are there other
different resources so what it looks
like is a unit starting with with
something we call black ships and
samurai which is about the American
Commodore Perry going to Japan and
opening what had been a then secluded
country we we have something called the
core exhibit and that's John's text so
when I when I met with John for the
first time John had about 40 pages of
straight text and a box of slides and he
said I want to do this thing and that
was where we began and so we began to
embed the images into into into his into
his text and there he began to you know
begin to take details out of these
images and I'm just going to move
through
very quickly and I'll tie this in to
where where we bring video into all of
this
but the adil the ability to break things
down to go into details what have you
was was it was clearly one of one of
John's one of the thrilling missions of
John to be able to draw you draw the
user in to be able to wrap his text as
I've said right around the imagery this
is another unit called Yokohama
boomtowns is after after Perry had come
the country opened Japan has now opened
up to foreign commerce and an
intercourse and trade and and one of the
things like the weed we had as the
producers on the project said to John is
you know this is people are going to get
lost in this text it's too much it's
it's too scholarly you know we need to
allow them another way into the content
that can then push them back into
something that's more textual and has
the depth that you want so we took some
of the themes that he had developed and
built something called the visual
narratives and that just took again it
took themes specific themes in his text
and broke them down took the images line
them up in a very you know graphic novel
or manga s way and adds added small bits
of text around them and allowed us to go
and even D in more detail onto the
images and so this is just an example of
what this looks like we have we have
about 15 of these units that are
available now about another 15 or in the
pipeline from there what we didn't want
to do was just limit it to John when
John develops or the other scholars we
work with develop content they they're
working with with hundreds and thousands
of images often and so we wanted to then
allow the users to the audience for this
to go in and look at a broad database of
images not just the images that the
scholars have picked out and said these
are the images that are valuable to look
at the broad contextualization of what
what had been created at the time so if
we have a hundred or 200 images in the
core exhibit or the visual narratives in
the database we will have up to four
thousand images associated with each of
the each of the units but but done in
context and on why that's why that's
important is one of the things that we'd
found in working with museums like the
Smithsonian and the Museum of Fine Arts
in Boston is they have these amazing
databases and they've you know they've
digitized things they're aggressively
putting them online but they're an
absolute morass and and and and to their
credit they're getting this the images
up there and and putting the content
online making them available to anyone
but it's very difficult to navigate
through these through four hundred
thousand images if you don't have some
level of contextualization some level
too granular way to bring that down into
a digestible number of images and to put
that number into a context into a
context that has some more further
relevance so what we done and and
museums have changed dramatically ten
years ago museums would not have allowed
sort of they would not have allowed the
walled garden to open up and one of the
things that we've done in working with
again with the Smithsonian and the MFA
is to say you leave you can keep the
images on your database allow us and so
what we've done at MIT is to build this
this this technology we call it the
shadow asset we go in and we build it we
build a Corral around a certain number
of images and one of the MFA units
that's that's four hundred images having
to do with the russo-japanese war 400
woodblock prints from their Scharf
collection that that might live on the
MFA's collection of four hundred
thousand at image number twenty five and
another one at image three hundred
ninety nine thousand so there's no
they're not they're not housed together
and again this is not what the museums
are charged with doing it would be great
if they could do it better but there we
credit the museum's with just getting
this content there it's the it's you
know it's the job of other folks like
like the John dollars to add some level
of context and then for technologists
and producers to then to put to put that
context in there as well as have it be
open and free and available to
anyway they want to use it in that in
that wild Corral so we what we've done
is pulled that content in again and then
say in the context of 400 images
associated with this this this
particular unit and we do that we can
also add our own metadata we've added it
we have so the content can all live on
the MFA s database but we can add our
own metadata to it to create an exposed
keyword database so you know the MFA
can't necessarily create a whole set of
metadata or keyword tagging schema for
their content but we can and we can do
it in context of the content that we're
presenting to to the user and that user
is again to get specific is a general
audience is a secondary a secondary user
and again two more scholarly scholarly
and academic users as well so that's
that's a that's a huge people in what we
do and by allowing that data that
database to be open and to be
contextualized in a way with it there's
a digestible amount of content to the to
general users and that level with that
added level of relevance we find that
users are very much empowered and then
go and create their own mashups create
their own motion graphic animations
create their own powerpoints their
slideshows whatever they may be using
that content using the metadata but then
using the scholarly materials or the
other materials and resources that we've
provided at some level of reference and
it's pretty early contained and
purposeful so in terms of video video is
a key element in what we do and we we
very much we want to be able to we know
we know the power of video allows a
general audience or anyone to get into
the into the content right away there's
no audio on this if you're I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna play something as I
as I close we appreciate the power of
videos I've said and what we've done
with a number with all of this we create
a scholarly text create the visual
narrative the graphic novel approach to
users another another way into the
content allow it large database of
materials for people to play with and
then also we provide some linear content
or some interactive media that that
again pulls the content together and and
begins to you know impart some level of
additional value or knowledge to it into
users who are taking in data in
different in different manners what I'm
showing you right now is something I did
in the collaboration with um with
roundabout theater and Stephen Sondheim
at Studio 54 a few years ago and just in
the way that the wonderful way the
collaboration forms they had seen this
project the folks at roundabouts and
Sondheim and he said you know instead of
this you know the the thousand words and
playbill that we're gonna have as he was
he was they were they were reviving
Pacific overtures which is about the
encounter between Perry and the Japanese
you know could you put together a short
animation that will play in the lobby
for people to be able to get an idea of
what was happening using the historical
images created by the Japanese and by
the Westerners and to juxtapose that and
to try to try to tell the story and
we're by working with Apple and other
people we we built this animation which
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna let run
but again you know the the mandate the
mandate for the project is to for
visualizing cultures is to create
scholarly content around visual imagery
and then to allow users to be able to
find their what if by whatever way they
feel most comfortable pathways into that
content into that rich depth of material
and then to create and and to purpose
their own content and again we provide a
number of tools we provide a number of
different platforms but largely you know
we want the content to just be the
content and whatever means people want
it to be and you know and we find that
if if we don't if we don't pull out this
content and allow and allow people
to you know allow scholars to a add
their their their pieces their their
information and their data to the
content and then have that content be
made more relevant to users of all
different levels the users then add
another level of relevance to that
content and and if that doesn't happen
these materials they you know this this
wealth of visual materials will
effectively rot in archives physical and
digital so so that's that's that's part
of the mission is just to continue to
get this material out there and to put
any scholar in context thank you